[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what's right to do
[Music]
for today
[Music]
so snail bits socially speaking of which
my wife called me and by the way thank
you for the thoughts and prayers my wife
is you know she's not walking that well
no she's getting there but it's funny
she's doing no I love my wife and I've
been trying to take care of her as best
I can she had a simple procedure that
she was going in for and then I got a
weird reaction to anesthetic and first
off let me okay have a lot to get to
right so we have some developments with
the Vandal from yesterday and Deep Ellum
we'll talk about that we're going to
talk about some of the worst most
egregious murders from the rioters today
what else are we talking about we're
talking about sponsors to get to I'll
ask you the question today in a couple
seconds but those who are watching on
YouTube of course subscribed to mug Club
ladders credit.com slash mug club you
can watch this live on the blaze not all
of this is on YouTube there's like a
whole other what is it audio way like a
half hour half hour at least more than I
think we're only on so many minutes yeah
so my wife had a simple procedure done
and they they like struck a nerve and so
she you know she had like this weird
static it's definite impinge to nerve I
don't know I've never seen this that's
one thing what how many six foot women
have you done this procedure on is a
call I see your point which is not what
you want to hear from a doctor like
calibrated like don't you have a
protractor avoid the nerves but she is
doing well that's good you're making
whatever that she can't walk yeah a
little bit a little bit
is it like a funny not walk like she
stumbles a little wobble your crow from
Wizard of Oz step throw an apple from a
writer tree okay yeah there you go
speaking of a salt and also will be
reading your chats chats are exclusively
available by the way at the mug club for
people we don't do it on YouTube because
they century and you know they suck
audio wait is here my half-asian larval
Richmond is not here that's true what
about Karen who are you sir hold it
don't the TV gerald a how are you i am
well sir how are you good I like that
rope people people don't ask you how
you're doing is most true going back a
tragic its
is tragic wade-brown heavy heavy is the
head in my case it's a it's a Burger
King crown because in the kids clubs I'm
not as heavy yeah you know it's not a
great crown and along with the whopper
jr. is just a piece of [ __ ] well at
least one of the Michael Jackson Kids
Club so you chose courageous cussing and
I don't appreciate it come on don't
don't lead with that when we know that
multiple stories from today could result
in us being bad Oh take me out I don't
want it to be over an MJ joke that's
true Jesus juice told you no not even
when I told right yeah so we are going
to be talking about uh well ex former
police officer who was whose life was
taking David Dorn today and I think it's
really an important story that isn't
being told and we have seen let's see if
they're telling it at CNN real quick
let's fact check let's see should not
have used the term battlespace regarding
protest sites that's the takeaway here
it really is about language about nuance
this is all about Trump going and taking
a picture at the church and visiting the
church that was almost bone burned down
and they can't get off of it yeah
absolutely cannot and that broad is the
whatever head of the Episcopal I don't
Aska poll I don't really know what it
means is it like Unitarian in Canada its
Anglican here it just seems like
silliness but before we move on and talk
about all of this we do have a sponsor
we have a new sponsor oh we are very
glad of course response to buy black
rifle coffee lot of clutter that comes
oh sorry
black rifle coffee comment router the
promo code creditor 20% off great coffee
veteran-owned pro-second amendment guys
and support them but we're also really
happy to have a new sponsor today
exercise with benefits such as
controlling your weight reducing the
risk of heart disease and an overall
lift in your mental health and mood
exercise is the obvious way to start
your morning and yet you still refuse to
do it
exercise can help your body manage blood
sugar and insulin levels
strengthen bones and muscles and even
reduce your risk of some cancers so why
in the name of Saint Sebastian don't you
I mean would it really be so hard some
people enjoy testing themselves and
their limb
experiencing growth accomplishment and a
general sense of victory over oneself
but not you you prefer to roll out of
your lukewarm bed into a lukewarm shower
eat a lukewarm breakfast and drive off
to work for people who don't care if you
live or die
exercise push yourself
for once with with that last shot was
that the girl from Game of Thrones it
was yeah that's gonna be a strike
couldn't get the eunuch with the hand
warmer who's the elliptical I realize I
could mind myself to fitness but what is
this Fitness really paying for before
Game of Thrones she had to do stock
footage did you long career lot of
actors get their start at Getty was it
Tom Hanks head bosom buddies right yeah
redhead from Game of Thrones has skinny
yeah media's change landscape is
changing so quick question I guess and
not to bring this down to be a downer
but you know we'll find a way to
hopefully make this entertaining but I
do think this matters this is very
important for you to know does David
Dorn's life matter folks do we do do we
what is anyone talking about it do you
know his name it was trending for about
half a second before we got to a another
bunch of lies that were trending on
tours right that these are peaceful
protests which by the at what point does
it cease to be a peaceful protest when
there's a riot in every single city
there's been a protest and we'll get to
it in a second as to why it's not the
exact same thing as people who show up
to the Capitol with scary automatic
weapons that phrase was wrong and so so
many levels so many things wrong um do
you even know who David Dorn is I want
to know people out there do you know who
he is do you know his story and why are
we not talking more about black police
officers yeah all right this is
something nobody is talking about
tomorrow we'll be doing another live CNN
fact-check stream is it at 8:00 p.m.
Eastern yes 8:00 p.m. Eastern about it
like it's necessary that's twice and one
I thought we did it last week right I
feel so helpless like I didn't make a
dent because I tuned in to CNN and Don
Lemon is going you know the
largely peaceful and named super largely
peaceful and wolf blitzer saying I have
walls what are you talking the toilet at
Home Depot it's a display wolf it's a
display again
somebody's gonna clean that no he's a
man for the environment of course yes
yes also not really well-known but you
know it's a wig and a beard on earthworm
jim so David Dorn I want to make sure
they have this right isn't he was a
police officer in st. Louis and then he
switched over to another district yeah
and he was not on duty this night of the
the riots the looting it's hard to kind
of put these pieces together but he was
helping to protect a friend's business
yeah that's what he was doing people
were rioting looting and he was shot
dead by a rioter he was shot dead by a
looter I believe for a television Wow
some other type of consumer electronics
yeah you know I don't really necessarily
know his matters no no no if it was a
vizio I've heard Westinghouse may play a
role in this lasting that's the looks
Big West is this marquee yeah and I warn
you that since everyone knows about the
George Floyd footage and by the way yeah
every single person here said that was
horrible very tough to watch that police
that policeman acted well outside the
realm of his authority had horrible
training and should be held accountable
I want to be really clear that matters
we all agree
you had us on your side and still until
you started burning down other people's
[ __ ] mm-hmm but since everyone has seen
that footage and it was disturbing and I
understand why I think it's important
that we show some of this footage so I
warned you of David Dorn who was shot
dead and I think we have a censored
version that you can find the whole
version online ot ot ot ot LT come on
stay with me og og stay with me stay
with me og stay with me oh gee come on
Ozzy come on Ozzy come on Ozzy stay with
me come on G come on G come on G stay
with me come on G come on G come on G
come on G hellmouth's of TV's Paul
I'm some TVs man for real
that's a mighty Quinn daddy cards do
Jess so you just use a racial what I'm
trying to do you Tom I got candies man
on some TVs car I want to take meetings
car you hear me get car I'm some TVs car
stop playing male G come on G come on G
daddy come on some TV call them cars
Oh some TVs cuz come on come come on man
we've had it in this curse over TV come
over TV pop them cuz he gone bro he gone
bro I was some TVs cuz I was G man rest
in peace bro and number love bro
you good bro it's okay bro just relax
bro relax bro relax bro oh it's a TV
used on right there used on the right
within each time protective edge science
HEIs the rock it's too much going on for
the og come on she was better than that
old [ __ ] I think he do work her man he
work here man I was a TVs man okay yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's insane now I know
I tweeted about this quite a bit before
and I was accused of being right and we
don't even know who killed that man
could be white could be brown could be
black could be yellow I don't care and I
don't care if you get mad that I said
yellow was opposed to asian-american a
life was lost there and if you look at
my tweets were accused of being racist I
said this is going to lead to more
deaths yeah
stop it please stop it you can go to the
tweets four or five days ago you can go
to the videos you can go to less
Thursday show us and please for the love
of God stop this and this isn't the only
black officer who's been killed by the
way no it's not the only person it's not
the only officer who's been killed there
have been many deaths and we'll get into
that tomorrow we need a live fact check
stream because I think it's important to
watch CNN
and see if they disgust I always you're
peaceful protesters peaceful protesters
people all the time sorry maybe the
majority of protesters are peaceful okay
let's assume that's true doesn't change
the fact that everywhere there have been
protests riots have ensued everywhere
outside of I believe Frisco but that's
because they know that Frisco don't play
like that
you know what's up but why don't we ever
hear most officers peaceful most
officers law-abiding and I understand
the problem is a number of but why don't
we talk if you are to compare the
percentage of protesters who are
peaceful the percentage of protesters
who are committing crimes and I don't
just mean shooting cops like we see
there all crimes any and all crimes to
police officers all I see on Twitter if
you ever had any doubt as to the social
media bias it is not the first off if
you type in black lives matter they have
three fists yeah three fists their
twitter has decided that they want to
toss their lot in with them and you
can't find anything regarding David Dorn
you can't find most of the trends I
think white lives matter was trending
for a little bit which again I not on
board with white lives matter black
lives matter I just want rule of law to
matter and I want people to not be shot
constitutional rights matter what does
that mean that means that you have the
right to life liberty pursuit of
happiness the police do not have the
right to accost you to invade your
personal space to invade your privacy
they do not have the right to abuse
authority that has not been delegated to
them and as a citizen you have the right
to protect your self with weapons yes
even this carries semi-automatics
against looters and riders that's what
matters whether you are black white red
yellow Z take your pick
I don't care but there are a lot of
black officers there are more right now
than ever I believe in American history
no one talks about them yeah there's
another officer killed it was um Patrick
Underwood yeah do you not remember his
name folks do you know his name any name
for Patrick underwear do you think
Patrick Underwood might even support
some of the protesters out there before
it went to looting do you think Patrick
under what might have been a useful
useful voice in reform if you want
reform don't you want the black officers
out there on your side but you're
shooting them dead for an LG you son of
a [ __ ] I hope you fry I hope you fried
you
tube you want to get pissed at this I
hope that you get lethal injection and
you've heard me say I don't really care
about capital punishment yeah whatever
the cheapest way to get rid of the trash
but in this case not in this case it's
not like it changes but I'm just saying
I'm speaking a little emotionally here
so I think I've earned the right to do
that because they don't always only
speak emotionally as we see on the left
right I think the facts do matter and
something else too well let me let me
say this real quick oh is that way let
me see me getting this this is one of
the one of the toughest videos I think
that we've ever had to watch her yeah
we've ever shown and obviously we've
seen a series of very tough videos over
the last we were very pissed about
Georgia very very pissed about that but
I my assumption was that they were
genuine when they said that all lives
matter
right and black lives matter and that if
we can only save one life that's been
the mantra right now
where are the leaders in every community
coming out and saying stop rioting
because people are dying in droves now
we've taken one death and turned it into
tens or dozens yeah or when is it going
to be hundreds of deaths how many bodies
does it take because you told me that we
don't want any people dying and that's
what we're all here for we're trying to
make sure that we can prevent that first
one from going away life it's a lot tip
the pursuit of happiness and then
Liberty you have to have life first
right I want any innocent lives lost I'm
not really clear yeah I understand you
invade someone's home but at least the
hounds then the rounds why aren't they
saying rioters did you say hounds do you
mean racist you're gonna put you're
gonna put me next to a Hitler with a
fake Bible side by side because you got
bad Photoshop there's had a lot of words
that rhyme with round so you had to go
with some drinks yeah counted I mean
Betty Betty's a sight hound I'm actually
glad that I have genital looking at
hopper was a little bit racist he would
rescue us he was rescued from Detroit
it's not his fault he can't really blame
him Betty doesn't really care though no
she has a clean slate she does she's
colorblind she's afraid of mirrors and
Indian food for some reason how did you
find this out I was eating Indian food
and she ran away scared she was
I noticed you she always comes up for
food Betty yes and she's all white so
another cup that's stacked against me
right now I was in you know if the
teacher don't take the food but she was
coming up when I was eating food and I
love a good go vindaloo before we go to
be on meat and processed crap
goats goats require far less and they're
far more sustainable it's a cultural
thing
goats we should just be eating more goat
and it's delicious and it's farmer come
up with cific G go like this should go
she like this every time I took the foot
to mouth you go wow I put in my mouth
shoots she runs in pajamas yeah did she
think you were eating dog or something
and she was offended by it or no no no I
didn't want a Chinese so oh here's
something else that people need to
realize and I think it's important that
these videos get out that these stories
get out because this changes the scale
not just of the election but of
Americans understanding where we are and
now you have the overwhelming majority
of Americans the overwhelming support I
should say to use the National Guard and
even Donald Trump using the military
which is so interesting when you look at
these polls they say oh we don't really
approve of Donald Trump's handling of
the crisis but then when you look at do
you support using the National Guard yes
do you support using the military yes
and I think that you're seeing this with
the polls people are afraid to say yeah
I support Donald Trump because people
have accused him of being racist but
when you look on the individual issues I
was very surprised yeah I was very
surprised as you know most Americans
believe in using the National Guard
because if you watch them that means
that Americans are making this decision
in spite of ABC NBC CBS CNN MSNBC every
place not named Fox News and it means
that YouTube is going to crack down even
more on borderline content like this
because they want to make sure that the
big boys have they want to make sure
they get any express lane 12 items or
less or a budget of 3 to 18 billion
dollars as we broadcast from Turner's
Bison farm well yeah this this David
Doran thing shows that it's never it's
not about black and white it really is
about power right so David Doran or if
he's standing in front of a store trying
to protect it he's perceived as having
some amount of you know if he owns the
business or if he's a cop he is
perceived as being the overlord and
they're the underdogs trying to fight it
but yeah but but if you can pretend it's
about all you can pretend it's about
black and white but really it's about
Marxism it's about power and equities
and people are trying to even those out
by murder which right which is that's
exactly what that is that is that is
cold-blooded murder
by the way here's a notification bail if
you're on YouTube the subscriptions
don't mean a lot hit all notifications
you can subscribe to Crowder bits we're
available on Spotify iTunes all that
please do consider joining Mudd Club
because we don't make money off of this
YouTube channel and this is the only way
that we can do the job that media won't
let me tell you this
George Floyd was and I'm about saison
that I know was gonna piss some people
off I don't really care anymore
George Floyd not that I really ever did
listen you pretty much about to get the
same on my heart score like thanks Joe
Rogan George Floyd was terrible this is
a worse tragedy all lives lost matter
every life is precious every light has
the same amount of value intrinsically I
want to be clear about that okay however
there is a difference let's say someone
being caught to use two scenarios in
crossfire right in crossfire between a
gang shooting and someone is shot that's
different from somebody invading
someone's home sticking the gun to their
gut and shooting them Yeah right that is
Tim and that's important to know George
Floyd should not have that he died in
the care of a police officer that
shouldn't have happened now was he
killed by the police officer the report
right now says likely not it wasn't from
a knee on the neck there was no sign of
injury in the neck he wasn't he wasn't
choked the guy did have high blood
pressure he had a heart disease like
we've got there have been a couple of
autopsies that have had mixed results
but yeah that's true well anyway and
we're not taking away the responsibility
of the play well there have been mixed
results but there haven't been there's
agreement on he had heart conditions he
had high blood pressure he was on drugs
okay doesn't mean that he should have in
other words it's the police
police's job not only to arrest you but
to protect you
yeah it is their job to try and help you
if you are sick so they can arrest you
get you in the car and I know they
couldn't get him in the car because he
was resisting arrest but my point is
that is a horrible scenario terrible but
it's not the same as this man being
killed one is an example of a police
officer who is I don't think he went out
and said I'm gonna Lynch me a black
today despite the fact that that's what
that's what the credit I want you guys
because they want to go out and they
want to they want to justify right now
all of their accounts of first degree
murder second degree murder in this case
it's manslaughter I think the guy was
careless
I think the guy had a reckless disregard
for someone's life and that is wrong
with the police now do I think that
that's racist it could have easily been
anybody in this case maybe it is we'll
find out more about you it shouldn't be
a controversial statement to say that
murder is worse than manslaughter it
shouldn't be and we've seen tapes of
both of those things happen and context
matters
listen shouldn't have died but when you
look at George Floyd the man was a
violent offender who did five years why
he broke and entered he faked like he
was part of the I believe a water
company or gas company when when a lady
who lived in the house tried to close
the door she shoved a pistol in her gut
and with five other armed thugs looted
did five years but he was turning his
life from no than he was resisting
arrest there were drugs in his system
none of this means that he should have
died but it does add wrinkles to where
there might be a struggle where there
might be chaos that's different from
someone consciously shooting someone for
a television set that is worse to me now
you want to say well it's about systemic
racism well you know what black cop died
too so we can apply that to both one is
murder
one is manslaughter and have I missed
anything has there been any evidence
that's come out that says that the
police officer was a racist or that this
was racially motivated in any way this
police officer no the police officer
that the killer vania yeah I don't know
no I haven't seen that at all
I mean you can make the claim that's
fine I just haven't seen anything that
says yeah it's a racist white cop that
killed my aunt if you hear important if
you hear a report on the news and it's a
cop who killed somebody and you're
waiting to hear what what color
everybody was to figure out how you're
supposed to feel about this right you're
the enemy
yeah you're a racist exactly exactly
this happen black or white well life is
look like a white well life is black or
yeah yeah I mean a cop was negligent in
how he handled a suspect right yeah and
that's how this person died and that's a
crime and he's going to end it all it
was different because one wasn't
innocent well as a plainclothes officer
and one is an entirely innocent civilian
who's committed no crime the other one
with with Floyd did commit a crime has a
history of violent crime was resisting
arrest doesn't mean the guy deserved it
I think you're in slaughter is
appropriate but we do need shouldn't be
a controversial statement to say hey if
you're a serial Reap if you're a repeat
violent offender resisting arrest
there's a much higher
likelihood that this ends violently then
if you're a police officer who has a
history of being a law-abiding citizen
you're trying to protect your friend
well that's not victim blaming either
that's just good advice yeah right if
you put yourself if you're a riot or
standing on a freeway that isn't closed
there's a higher likelihood that you're
gonna get hit by a car that doesn't know
you guys are rioting right you know
highway like it's just good advice not
to do that you're gonna stop and ask
your cause yeah you coming around the
turn or something no mace to perform a
very environmentally friendly the mace
has been smoking really well lately
the bear is not a great year I don't get
the feedback with your your felony spray
paint can it doesn't make the yeah
that's very about that it's working this
is one thing that really bothers me too
because you you lose the whole problem
when you think that it's just police
brutality against black people yeah who
said of the prom there is a problem with
militarization of some police forces
there is a problem a lot of police think
that it's their job to control us it is
their job to serve us I saw the police
shooting a lady on her on her porch
after curfew I don't know if this was
Minneapolis which city it was she was on
her own porch now that could be a
misunderstanding he is still it's a cop
general rule-of-thumb
don't shoot people with paintball guns
on their own porch yes I have a problem
with that I want to be with it very
clear but if you just look at it's black
versus well it's cops versus black
people well you ignore the black
officers if you look at is just systemic
racism you don't acknowledge the problem
of the militarization of police in
certain districts and the need for
citizens to defend themselves with the
Second Amendment by the way it doesn't
just apply to looters and riders it does
apply to corrupt police as well it does
matter this is one thing that really
bothers me that a lot of people bring up
you think it's a checkmate argument when
it's the opposite yes it's the opposite
of that when they say hoo it's white
abuse what about those armed protesters
who show up to the Michigan Capitol
first up was entirely white people you
can see this across country there
black people who own scary black rifles
just to be clear heads up there are
plenty of black people who didn't know
here's the main divot or semi-automatic
between that automatic and the black
lives matter okay they didn't commit any
crimes yeah that's the big difference
crime but they were different okay well
some of them went inside that's also not
a crime they showed up the in commit
crimes beforehand they didn't commit
crimes there here's something that
matters it's not the big difference yeah
black lives matter
encourage crimes criminal criminal
enterprise organization I know it's
fractured if you look at the leadership
there is not enough condemnation here
hey if you want to ask me do i condemn
white supremacists find one and I will
yeah find me one you know pull them out
I haven't seen one in years I haven't
seen one since I watched American
History X in the eighth grade yeah
though I know that everyone here
allegedly is including the black guy so
let's compare armed protesters you may
not like that they have guns you may not
like that they didn't commit any crimes
now let's take into account that gun
owners particularly a concealed carry
permit holders are far more likely to
obey the law I think we have an overlay
here we've talked about this on the show
concealed carry permit holders obey the
law at a significantly higher rate even
even more than police officers more than
police operators which is more than
general population yes so does this
matter do you think that police do you
think state officials take that into
account when they are gauging what kind
of reinforcements and reaction they need
they go hold on a second okay well we
have a bunch of armed protesters who are
out there defend their second Amendment
rights let's look at it statistically
it's not a threat yeah versus black
lives matter versus any time there is
there are protests over race related
incidents they always end violently now
let's also look at the crime rates here
while we're talking about this if you
look at the crimes committed by
individuals of different races against
individuals of different races you see a
far higher percentage of crime committed
by black people against white people
than white people against black people
by black people against black people
than white people against black people
and then if you look at these black
lives matter
riots protests as they're called well
apparently they're synonyms now they are
yes you see a far more violent history
so statistically there's a huge
difference and of
police will gauge their response based
on that yeah you may not like the optics
and I didn't think it was good optics I
don't think you should go out with it
with an open carry weapon unless you
plan to use it I think you should just
practical advice but you have the right
to do it but people like oh you know
this just shows how different the
treatment is of white people in the
system Colonel Hall second let me
actually give you an extreme example if
that person is out there with magazines
loaded to the gills and for some reason
he even does have a stamp permit to have
a suppressor on his rifle which is legal
or fully automatic which is almost
impossible to come by and he is out
there he has a scary mask and a don't
tread on me flag guess what that still
is a more law-abiding citizen then even
the guy who's completely unarmed but
throws a water bottle at a cop you have
made a decision because there are
concrete water bottles as well yeah
there are water bottles with with acidic
agents in there we saw that with with
milkshakes the plaintiff Oh was doing as
well it was all most of it some of that
myself guess what one is scary one you
don't like one has already committed a
crime regardless of what all bro a water
bottle bro a water bottle yeah you know
what a water bottle that guy can't take
a risk that black cop at whom you threw
it right because he needs to get home to
his family he's not worried about
getting home to his family because some
guy named judge showed up with a sniper
rifle oh yeah and by the way these cops
that are on the front lines of these
rights it's not like they are like us
we're sitting at home and watching this
on television yeah completely separated
from violence our pulse is not racing
and our thoughts aren't going oh my god
I hope I make you speak for yourself
right it's a different than the average
person sitting there watching it going
well if somebody threw a water bottle at
me I wouldn't look yeah you're in a
state where of course you could make
that decision and be like oh that's fine
it's a water bottle right there on the
frontlines of a riot they know they have
seen footage of fellow police officers
being dragged or being you know trying
to be dragged behind a protester line so
that they could beat the crap out of
them or god knows what remember the lady
in Chicago yeah and the other cops are
trying to pull her back right that's
what they're going out thinking can you
imagine being a police officer right now
going and getting your riot gear on and
going and walking out there and standing
out there so these thugs can go get
their Air Jordans from the Nike store
that they want to loot and just making
sure they're out of Jordan could be a
guy named Lyle stealing Skechers
my adidas was that you're steaming face
David Dorn
Patrick Underwood how about how about we
get this hashtag trending hashtag black
cops matter hashtag black cops matter I
want to see everyone using this out
there because I want them to know that
we support them not only white guys not
only a bunch of privileged folks or
quarter black people when they when
people have neo-nazi nightmares they
make sure yeah I don't think a picture
you just add Norman six-four plate at
Notre Dame didn't go to Alabama
could you we know what's happened all
right I don't know that much more to say
on that I just I do have a book here
right so Donald Trump actually tweeted
something out it was a very nice tweet
on this and saying you know honoring his
memory Dorn's memory and saying that you
know we should get the killers right so
it was a very nice tweet it wasn't
political the best tweet yes it was very
much so the best week and then a
filmmaker Ava Duvernay do presented
juvenile your name doesn't make any what
is she doing she quoted wrinkle yeah
that's what I asked to wrinkle in time
yes okay time-traveling shar-pei was an
adaptation of it okay oh you gotta clean
their wrinkles I think it's gonna
definitely do so here really so no joke
yeah is no joke don't screw around with
it I heard her response to Donald
Trump's tweet which was totally fun
right we've got on the screen right now
it says we won't let you use this black
man for your political gain you can try
looking like an the overly may he rest
in peace me the truth about his murders
come to light and may he not have his
name dragged into your vicious evil
games are you serious the president of
United States just came out and said
this is a horrific crime and I'm
honoring the member the the memory of
this police officer and your response to
him is get his name out of your mouth
get it out of your vicious evil schemes
we're not gonna let you lose him for
political goals yes stop using dead guys
for political gain that's our thing yeah
I guess yeah I don't I don't think
that's our thing no I guess that's what
Duvernay is saying did you also
on Memorial Day and say hey when you
said thank you to all the troops who
have laid down their lives for this
country do you say get their names out
of your mouth I won't let you use them
for a political stunt is that your
answer every time we try to it's very
clear to see the narrative they see the
black lives matter activists out there
and by the way that means and woke white
people as well they see them as the
freedom fighters yeah
they see them as the freedom fighters
and now unfortunately because the
military has out of necessity been
brought in they see them as oppressing
the freedom fighters they're just like
they're just like terrorists in the
Middle East well police organizations
are local right National Guard local to
the state the governor calls them and if
you've got a problem with how your state
is handling this look at your local
aphasia you know what else and I totaled
Trump as well like people going oh look
at these peaceful protesters and cops
reacting most the time what you're
seeing is cops setting up a barricade
a violent riot and then protesters yeah
guys hold on keep it down there and you
are I think I saw her one-man show onesy
show you have to say I walked out after
she got out of the turtleneck and went I
am born why did you walk in in the first
place I checked out after ultimatum yeah
I'm like I'm like Rasheeda Talib she can
legally block it bad filmmakers can
legal right and I'm sure she also
positive about this what you're usually
seeing and this happens quite a bit look
I'm peaceful
well what often happens when I would
often what has happened in every single
city is there some kind of a violent
riot and then police have to set up a
barricade certainly for the White House
when you're trying to storm the White
House yeah they have to set up a
blockade and then people or behind the
police line guess what if you're behind
a police line you're not peaceful
you're not peaceful I'm sorry and you
also have no business being out there if
other people are rioting and eluding
around you yeah get out of there
sorry it's no longer peaceful if you go
to a - of meeting with the Crips it's
like I was I was I was just there like I
wasn't even I would
document I was da key I'm a
documentarian though yeah really can I
see your body of work I started yet
everybody's gotta start somewhere so Joe
its Getty Images or YouTube yeah all
right i-i'll get your sketches and get
out of here yeah right you right you
right let me go only one free pair yeah
one for customer that's what really
pisses me off one ah man they're
stealing the hand sanitizer through here
not abiding by one per customer they are
not abiding by any of their social
distancing rules right now that's one
thing that we know in Dallas by the way
and this is something I'll be talking
with Manny about if you think that it's
wrong to paint over graffiti because for
some reason there's this entitlement
mindset that if it's a mural it's art
how about I piss my name on your
pillowcase well yeah exactly it's not
yours what if you just went into the art
store him like which one this one 4995
sorry it's our now it's alright now it's
you don't call Shotgun
we're not awaiting see down there
alright it's not like we're facing we're
gonna be talking about Seth Rogen and we
will be updating you on the Vandal in
Dallas interesting developments there
hint woke privilege and [ __ ] but for
right now this is our good